bella a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi andiamo avanti con scriba losi pare
che avevamo 36 st wright ce n'è ma
allora ragazzi mancano due zone
e poi abbiamo finito scriverlo circa 16
st wright se tutto va bene ma ancora tre
o quattro puntate in teoria dovremmo
aver finito scribblenauts non lo so
comunque direi di andare avanti allora
ci rimangono quattro strike per
sbloccare la parte nuova quindi direi di
andare sulle piramidi che mi ispirano
tomba di ok non ho fatto in tempo a
leggere tomba di onomatopea così perché
allora c'è o di un ladro cioè lara croft
cela la croce indiana jones
ci sono tutti ok ragazzi manca soltanto
bear grylls poi ci siamo
bene direi di andare avanti ok c'è
indiana l'avevo l'aveva uccisa non
episodi precedenti ma è tornato in vita
aiutami a decifrare questi geroglifici
ok ma che cazzo che razza di geroglifici
sono vabbè mi fate capire cosa dovrei
chi è questo posso quasi leggere questi
geroglifici puoi dirmi cosa significano
è che lavorano ma capirà conchiglia è
una chiocciola una chiave chiocciola una
donna che scrittura chiocciola un
mollusco vice vieni decifra questo ce lo
fa cazzo ti sei innamorato di una
chiocciola
vabbè io come al solito non faccio
domande
spero che la storia d'amore vada a
finire bene io vado su c'è lara croft
resta trappola pericolosa 20 qualcosa di
appiccicoso prima che perda un braccio
quale trappola questa trappola cosa
dovrei fare ce ne so chewing gum come si
scrive ceo in gomma madonna jay staccato
avevi se ne frega mai cosa lega legale
galega vai
ma cosa la smaterializzato non ha
funzionato vabbè ci sono cose che non
capirò mai perché c'è una mummia con la
valigetta tom baroni hanno rubato i
nostri mobili puoi darci qualcosa per
sostituirli è che ne so che mobili vuoi
che ne so divano sabbioso va bene allora
facciamo mensola sabbiosa ti va bene
mensola non la conosci la parola mensola
va bene cucina antica ok è l'unica cosa
che mi viene in mente ma è un frigo
perfetto ma ci manca al forno e ci siamo
perfetti devono andar bene con le tende
ma chi se ne frega ci sia come il come c
è perché c'è gandhi ci siamo non sa che
sfida aiuta il becchino a creare una
mummia eterna perché dimmi solo perché
non lo so non lo capirò mai ma noi
iniziamo basta che mi sganci last light
e va bene la creazione di una mummia
voglio troppo vedere che cazzo esce
fuori allora va bene ci sono gli occhi
highstyle col pennello che cazzo cos'è
sta roba ma e frankenstein non è una
mummia
vabbè buongiorno aiuta l'impresario di
pompe questo è un impresario di pompe
funebri a preparare una mummia comincia
mettendo qualcuno di importante della
macchina per produrre sarcofaghi
facciamo fa vj fa vj abbastanza
importante vai se magnifica
no perché non va bene ma vige non è
abbastanza importante che so io qualcuno
di import che so
abramo lincoln abraham lincoln perché ci
trovo lì con iscritte no vabbè
ammettiamo mifi chiamò abramo lincoln
vai
poi aggiunge qualcosa in cui si può
avvolgere la mummia perfetto rotolo di
carta igienica ok igienica va bene vai è
un papiro va bene così era la carta
igienica degli egizi va bene infine
aggiunge un composto per
l'imbalsamazione io direi di usare un
qualcosa di molto fine professionale
facciamo il pongo il pogo il poco di
scriverla non va bene cosa ma che cazzo
per chiesto rockol poco sono diventato
steve
vabbè
pazienza a sto punto direi di fare un
chewing gum come abbiamo fatto prima
prima non sapevo scrivere adesso non lo
so piu scrivere perchè mentre parlo io
non riesco a scrivere michael chewing
gum riempì questo è un composto
professionale per l'imbalsamazione che
cazzo perché c'è torni sotto costa
facendo oddio oddio che cazzo è uscito
richard benson mummificato perché va beh
noi prendiamo la storia va bene ci siamo
sia lo zio acrobazie sul poco raga
incredibile soltan
ma neanche steve e riesce a farle
continuava ai 37 st wright ne mancano
tre
no veramente raga è stata una cosa
assurda come ci arrivo di sopra se non
predico correttamente il futuro il
faraone mi seppellirà vivo è il faraone
abramo lincoln e gia seppellito vivo ma
comunque non importa va bene c'è un
passaggio segreto le riuscire a predire
il futuro allora facciamo sfera di sera
buonasera anche a te sfera di cristallo
cristallo madonna mia che scrittura vai
13 tutto secondo il dio che cazzo
arrivato google
ma cos'è che sta succedendo da quando
nevica sotto 40 gradi me lo dovete
spiegare ma vabbè a sto punto direi di
cambiare zona perché non è normale
andiamo qui dove c'è willy il coyote
kenny un polveroso perfetto se tutto va
bene raga dovrei riuscire a sbloccarmi
l'ultima perché c'è un cavallo morto che
cazzo oddio c'è un impiccato ma perché
c'è odio billy the kid ci sono tutti c'è
anche chi cazzo vabbè c'è c'è cos'è
quello raga io voglio sapere perché
ditemi perché c'è un bufalo volante rega
prima di proseguire volevo fare una cosa
che mi avete consigliato da tanto
praticamente mi avete consigliato di
fare la macchina del tempo anche se non
ho mai capito che cazzo fosse che bella
direi di entrarci a sto punto perché non
ho mai capito
ok non sbagliato perfetto non ho mai
capito che cazzo fosse così ci sono
addio
cos'è sono diventato abramo lincoln
perché no che preferisco modificato che
è successo di una vecchia pellicola è
fantastico
cioè cos'è sta roba è una picca
raccogliamo la picca facciamo cadere il
lancio addio che cazzo ho fatto non
volevo fa ho buttato giù il bisonte che
si è materializzato in un sedano
io credo di non aver capito bene come
funziona il corpo degli esseri viventi
credo forse mi hanno insegnato vale da
piccolo ma normalmente un bisonte non si
smaterializza in un sedano faroni in
porta va beh non fa intanto quella corsa
giovan co avesse visto un hamburger del
mcdonald ma non importa c'è il mio
cappello ad abramo lincoln me lo devo
mettere perché non posso stare senza
e c'è anche del del condimento per
insalate e del gorgonzola
ma che cazzo di bisonte ucciso c'era beh
direi di andare avanti lo stesso dato
che la sfida tanto ormai andata [ __ ]
quindi va bene lo stesso chi è questo è
ovvio lanciato sedano direi che posso
partecipare alle olimpiadi di lancio del
sedano perché le vinco un bandito mi ha
rubato il veramente sembri tu il bandito
ma non importa mi ha rubato il denaro
aiutami a recuperarlo toni traversi di
romantica premi l'interruttore per
entrare nel covo ok è come cazzo ci si
traveste da bandito passamontagna nel
far west
vai cos'è sta roba
mi sembra un criminale da quattro soldi
va beh interagisci vale andiamo apriti
sesamo se andiamo
buongiorno sono ladro come vuoi vedi
cioè il passamontagna c'è una pistola
maninalto maninalto brutto stronzo è ok
non siamo amici va bene ok devo devo
controllare se ho lasciato il sandwich
nel caveau e stai tranquillo non voglio
rubare niente devo soltanto controllare
se ho lasciato il mio sandwitch swat a
bastardo bastardo è il mio sangue cioè
la pistola brutto stronzo vinco io dico
no cazzo siete in due non vale cos'è
prendetevela con una della vostra taglia
che sarà di 23 mila dollari ma non
importa allora mandiamoci più sul
pesante bazooka
vai cos'è mai mettersi contro fa vj
brutti bastardi muore o cazzo ok o quasi
ucciso l'altro però devo recuperare il
bottino prima perfetto mai mettersi
contro fa vj con un passamontagna
ok ci sono ragazze ndiamo il denaro
andiamo fuori ce l'ho fatta fa vj
salvatore ha recuperato tutti i tuoi
soldi bene in effetti si erano di più di
quanti ne avevo dato io di sicuro
ok dove la mia paga adesso che ti ha
aiutato esiguo appunto un compenso per
quello che ho fatto ovviamente un lavoro
gratis
quindi direi che è questo è mio zio chi
è questo no che bastardo mi ha rubato
brutto stronzo mio questo mela mi han
dato la paga è mio
vabbè lasciamo perdere
brutto stronzo di merda sono miei ma
guarda che vabbè tieniteli [ __ ]
salvami direi che che sei morta da un
bel pezzo ma vabbè sto punto levo la
corda per parlarci tu col pezzente di
merda che mi dia i soldi cos'è questo
15.000 dollari lo prendo io
la banda del tosto imburrato in fuga
cattura di tutti e con segnali allo
sceriffo mai ci sono
devo ricercato perfetto però li voglio i
15.000 è chi cazzo è questo mio dio cioè
si è nascosta devo trovare i banditi che
si nascondono sono cioè sono introvabili
sono nascosti da dio non si vedono
veramente c'è tanta quello è lo sceriffo
perfetto
bene io so che cazzo di buffy ciò attira
video cercatore d'oro gary fuori dal suo
nascondiglio e consegnerà lo sceriffo
soldi direi che coi soldi ci dovrei
riuscire in qualche modo non so neanche
chi cazzo è sto gary ok ci sono riuscito
beh allora lui l'ha preso perfetto kenny
non resisto che per che cazzo si fa
chiamare non resisto e è il prossimo va
beh non importa dove store non resisto e
di sopra che cosa dovrei fare per non
resisto che insomma andare a cagare che
ti serve la carta igienica carta
igienica i geni igienica
madonna non so scrivere carta igienica
ok
vai dove andrà
ma che cazzo è successo ma cosa vuol
dire veramente dobbiamo andare a cagare
c'erano capita è rimasto solo un bandito
lo arresta canna la ladra di cappelli ok
la ladra di cappelli perché ho un
cappello qui non so se è perfetto ci
siamo
hai un capello in più tanto per cambiare
non lo so direi un berretto ti manca il
berretto vero è l'unico tipo di cappello
che ti manca perfetto ci sia addio
perché il sole sta dando fuoco a tutto
di esplode tutto perfetto
anna è stata catturata che cazzo
successo e se sul sole ha preso tutto
fuoco va bene non importa abbiamo la st
wright poche domande va bene così ajmad
torrent the skin ai catturate tutte
banditen io prenderei starai ten ce l'ha
fatta
ricercato completato raga 38 st wright
voglio provare a fare una puntata un po
più lunga raga visto che non so neanche
quanto gira fuori magari esce più corta
del solito che i tagli che faccia ma
vabbè diciamo di no devo provare a
raggiungere il 40 st wright così a meno
nella prossima puntata abbiamo già le
zone nuove aiutiamo sto povero vecchio
che è il mio cavallo sto male sono
bloccato qui ok perfetto
crebbe medicina anzi no beh veterinario
ci sia veterinaria va bene anche ma
anche femmina
questo sarebbe una una una veterinaria
donna
hai fatto un intervento di recente non
lo so vabbè non importa mai poi di cosa
al cavallo perfetto è un maestro nel
curare sarà anche brutta come donna ma è
veramente brava nel suo lavoro
ti ho anche aiutato corto passante tumi
picchi è stato voi ha rubato i soldi non
io brutto stronzo guardalo già che ci
sono ragazzi penso io a fare fuori sto
bastardo
oddio che cazzo è successo ha fatto la
carambola va bene dai mettiamolo per
stavolta ci sta
[Musica]
ok ragazzi sono mi manca soltanto le
dune up chat che cazzo sono devo andare
qui perché
oddio che cazzo è sta roba oh mio dio
che che figo 9 queste veramente c'è di
nuovo lara croft
vabbè c'è un mimo un faraone c'è di
tutto
va beh noi andiamo avanti kick ass
questo e beethoven
devo aiutare il mio regno con una
pozione perché queste piton con una
funzione per cambiare forma ma ho
bisogno di altri tre ingredienti
velenosi
il cianuro veleno veleno a caso proprio
così perché ok se addio che cazzo è
diventato non volevo
non era mia intenzione dragan addio che
cazzo oddio che così è diventato
serpente scaltro non facciamo domande
andiamo ma chi è questa filosofo achille
sembra raggiungere latakia achille
quello e achille sembra raggiungere la
tartaruga ma non può farlo se solo
potersi misurare questa corsa clessidra
a stop by misura che no è caduta
tieni ok risolvi il paradosso perfetto
che cazzo di paradosso è cosa vuol dire
fare cosa stai facendo achille non fare
cose scene in pubblico con le tartarughe
vai piano che ci sono anche dei bambini
qui
va beh noi andiamo avanti lasciamoli
soli
c'è chi cazzo è questo sembro io col
burqa la vorrei anche io ma quello che
mi facesse un obelisco perché cazzo c'è
mimmo devo trovare un verme delle sabbie
attratto dal rumore batteria checa
batteria musica vai così da c dentro
vino perfetto dio no si sta cappottando
che cazzo è sta roba
ok e non è esattamente quello che
pensavo verme delle sabbie ok totale
saletti 40 ce l'abbiamo fatta
vai da lì lì ci siamo ora che abbiamo
sbloccato le nuove zone io amo questo
videogame è un peccato raga che stiamo
arrivando alla fine mi dispiace
veramente tantissimo che cazzo ci fa big
daddy di bioshock
ok è un po più me lo ricordano un po più
ok che cosa vuol dire questo
addio c'è la tartaruga speriamo arrivi
anche a chi non c'è ok perfetto andiamo
con la tartaruga
devo andare inseguire un uomo che
cavalca un delfino sulla terraferma non
mi chiedete perché ma va bene così noi
proseguiamo allora abbiamo sbloccato la
zona nuova
io sono veramente curiosissimo ragadi
beccare questa qua dove ci sono i raggi
x che veramente dovrebbe essere
fantastico ma per ora limitiamoci ad
andare nell'isola puntino che cazzo è
l'isola puntino spiegatemelo va bè
ragazzi rally concludere qui l'episodio
aspettatevi di tutto questa settimana
perché veramente deve uscire
praticamente di tutto
a parte finali e pc this land eredi di
cat mario anche la nuova serie horror e
video dei 20.000 c'è deve uscire per la
mente ogni cosa questa settimana quindi
tenetevi pronti come al solito servi
dove è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
in ogni video trovate nella descrizione
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
bella ragazzi